let your voice be heard the ero making
program and EPA invite you to
participate in the rulemaking matters
video contest make a short creative
video that highlights the importance of
federal regulations and motivates others
to participate in the rulemaking process
you see federal agencies develop an
issue hundreds of rules and regulations
every year while Congress writes a
statute to create a new program or
change in existing one they provide an
outline of the program federal agencies
implement the statutes programs and/or
changes and they do this by developing
and issuing rules and regulations most
people are familiar with how a bill
becomes a law but most people don't
understand how federal agencies develop
an issue rules or that everyone has a
chance to provide their input into those
rules this is where we need your help we
invite you to capture the public
imagination and use creativity artistic
expression and innovation to explain why
regulations are important to everyone
and motivate others to participate in
the rulemaking process we will then
review all video entries select a winner
and award the winner with a grand prize
of twenty five hundred dollars as well
as post their video on our websites
remember the contest ends on Monday May
seventeenth 2010 let your voice be heard
submit a video today